et parlons transport à présent la sncf
inaugure un nouveau dispositif un peu
particulier grâce à lui le souterrain de
la gare de trappes est désormais propre
des murs anticipe anti incivilités ont
été placés dans les coins de ce
souterrain l'objectif dissuader les
usagers d'uriner dans les angles alors
grâce à la mise en place de ces plaques
de projection to liquid projetées sur le
mur retourne donc immédiatement sur son
propriétaire et la boucle est bouclée
le dispositif devrait s'étendre à la
gare de la verrière prochainement
nous sommes allés demander aux voyageurs
de cette gare ce qu'il pensait de ce
nouveau dispositif
écoutez leurs réponses il faudrait
généraliser je pense parce que vraiment
dans les souterrains et tout ça au
niveau des trains ou métro ça sent
énormément qu'on n'a vraiment énormément
de mauvaises odeurs je passe ici tous
les jours j'ai pas spécialement fait
gaffe mais je trouvais c'est une bonne
idée
après au niveau de l'odeur je pourrais
pas vous dire j'ai pas fait gaffe mais
je pense que c'est de l'argent dès que
dépensés pour rien parce que ça sent
toujours le riz n'ai je pas remarqué de
changement limite on n'a plus envie de
passer par là et là il ya déjà beaucoup
de jeunes qui passent en plein milieu
des voix parce que bon c'est ce qui sera
plus est
mais s'ils ont envie d'avoir temps mais
souvent ça puis l'on prend le stress par
là